Wow. A big, big thank you
to the Youtube Ai Algorithm.
Thank you. Ai. Hello world.
It's arrived in computers are pretty good
at learning from spreadsheets of data
filled with numbers,
but we humans communicate
with words not with numbers.
The subfield of AI called natural
language processing or NLP is focused on
enabling computers to understand
and communicate in human language.
In this video I'll cover how NLP
has progressed over the years.
Up until 2019 they don't explain how
to use a bleeding edge model called irt
that makes it incredibly easy for anyone,
not you,
for anyone to build NLP apps right now.
We'll specifically use Burke to learn
from a Dataset of Amazon reviews that
perform text classification
and automatic summarization.
Language is a way to represent
information and we humans interpret this
information from strings of text by
assessing three different criteria,
syntax,
semantics and pragmatics basically and
review syntax describes the form of the
language usually specified by grammar.
Natural language is much more complicated
than the formal language is used for
programming. There are many
rules of syntax to abide by.
I before e except after
c with 923 exceptions.
Semantics describes the meaning of
words or sentences of the language and
pragmatics describes how the words
relate to the world at large.
It's about considering their context to
understand the difference between these
three criteria. Take a look at
the following four sentences.
The first sentence is appropriate at the
start of an article, it's syntactically,
semantically and pragmatically correct.
The second sentence is syntactically
and semantically correct,
but pragmatically it
sounds kind of whack AAF.
The third sentence is
syntactically correct,
but semantically incorrect and the
last sentence is incorrect on all three
fronts. Syntactically
semantically and pragmatically.
Computer scientists have been creating
automatic systems to attempt to do this
for just about 60 years now,
which makes it an incredibly
young scientific discipline.
We can trace the history of NLP back
to 1950 when the prominent computer
scientists and it it Cumberbatch,
I,
I mean Alan Turing published a landmark
paper titled Computing Machinery and
intelligence,
which proposed what's now called the
Turing test as a criteria on of true
intelligence.
The question the Turing test poses is
can a computer program fool a human into
thinking it's a human via conversation?
A few years later, Noam Chomsky,
a prominent linguist published a book
titled Syntactic structures which detailed
a rule based system of how to structure
a grammatically correct phrases and this
inspired many rule based approaches to
NLP generating a sentence was usually
done by pulling syntactic
information from a database. In fact,
up until the 1980s most NLP systems were
based on a complex set of hand written
rules, but in the late 1980s hair
metal became an unfortunate reality.
On a more related note,
a revolution in NLP occurred when
researchers started using machine learning
algorithms for language processing
instead of rule based algorithms.
Mostly because the increase in available
computational power allowed for this
strategy to outperform rule based systems.
Some of the earliest use
learning algorithms like
decision trees produce systems
of hard if then rules similar
to existing handwritten rules,
but as time progressed,
researchers increasingly
favorite statistical models
which make probabilistic
decisions as to what a word or sentence
should sound like or mean instead of
rule based decisions.
Nowadays and LP systems like speech
recognition software rely on such
statistical models to predict which
words were likely spoken by a user,
which are more reliable. Alexa, show me
a photograph. Photograph by Nico Bath.
Know a class of statistical models
called deep neural networks.
Have been the key driver in most of
the recent NLP successes across a wide
variety of tasks like machine translation,
automatic summarization
and sentiment analysis.
And in 2019 free open
source tools like Pi,
torch colab and various text datasets
have enabled individuals and teams from
across the globe to create powerful
applications that use NLP to solve real
world problems.
For example,
clever who is a finished startup providing
an instance site search solution for
ecommerce stores.
They're using text classification to
provide relevant search results for
shoppers and actionable
insights for store owners.
Another startup called English central
aims to make learning English much more
fun by giving users instant feedback
on their pronunciation using speech
recognition techniques.
Yummly is building a platform for
recipe recommendations and search.
They use NLP to understand,
analyze and connect users with the
recipes they most enjoy old on cowboy or
cowgirl.
Before you go build an NLP startup
immediately you need to understand one
concept really well,
Burt,
which stands for bi-directional and
coder representations from transformers.
I'll explain what each of
those words mean in a second.
Bert is a fully trained language model
that Google released just a few months
ago and it's been the most significant
breakthrough in NLP thus far.
A language model is able to learn the
probability of word occurrence based on
examples of text.
Traditionally,
language models are trained by using the
previous end words to predict the next
one,
but ERT is a language model
that was trained by using
both the previous and next
words when making predictions,
hence the word bi directional.
Instead of unit directional.
Burt was used to establish a new state
of the art in 11 and LP tasks including
question, answering sentiment
analysis and automatic summarization.
All of these tasks involve
a two step process,
train a deep language
model on some text data,
then give those representations
to a task specific model.
For the first step of this process,
the Goto technique for the past few years
is called word to Vec and it creates
word representations
also called word vectors.
It maps each word in the training
Dataset to a vector that represents some
aspect of its meaning.
So for example,
the word vector for teen would include
information about state and gender.
These representations are generally
trained on large unlabeled data like a
Wikipedia dump.
Then use a train models on labeled
data for tasks like sentiment analysis.
This allows models to leverage linguistic
data learned from larger datasets.
The problem with word two VEC and similar
word vector techniques was that they
didn't take context into account.
The Word Bank, for example,
would have a different meaning
depending on the context it was used in.
They have trouble capturing the
meaning of combinations of words.
These limitations motivated the use of
recurrent networks as language models.
Instead, instead of training a model
to map a single vector for each word,
if these techniques train a neural network
to map a vector to each word based on
the entire surrounding context.
Nowadays,
the transformer,
a newer type of neural network,
has eclipsed all variations of recurrent
networks for language modeling.
A transformer consists of an encoder
network and a decoder network.
So the phrase Bert means
using a transformer network
to create by Directional
encoder representations.
These representations can then be fed
into another model for some specific NLP
task.
Unlike recurrent networks,
transformer networks like Bert don't
use recurrent connections at all.
They instead use attention over
the word sequence. Instead,
attention is defined in neuroscience as
the ability to selectively concentrates
on one aspect of the environment
while ignoring the rest.
In deep learning, we mimic this concept
through the use of attention mechanisms.
One way of doing this is to encode an
input sequence into not a single fixed
vector,
but instead have a model.
Learn how to generate a vector for each
output time step by adding an additional
set of weights that
will later be optimized.
So it doesn't just learn what to output.
It learns how to selectively way parts
of the input data to maximize the
likelihood of the proper output.
Burt is composed of several attention
blocks to prevent it from having ADHD like
I do. Each block transforms the
input using matrix operations.
If we input as sequence of n words,
the encoder will output
a sequence of tensors.
These tensors are used by the decoder
to output a sequence of words.
The architecture is optimized
using gradient descent
linked to how that works in
the video description.
The great thing about Bert is that it
comes fully trained out of the box.
It took Google four days using several
cloud TPU use to train it on several
languages.
So thank you Google.
I guess all we need to do is fine tune
the final layer of Burt on our own
training Dataset for whatever task we
choose and it will benefit from Burt's
existing knowledge. So let's look
at our data set of Amazon reviews,
which we'll use for two
tasks. Text classification
and automatic summarization.
I text classification. We're talking
about classifying chunks of text.
That could be anywhere from sentence
size to an entire paragraph in length as
either a good review or a bad review.
We'll first clone Bert
into our environment.
Then we'll download
the Burton model files.
These are wait values that represent
what it's learned from pre-training.
Then we'll need to preprocess our
data into a format that Bert expects.
Column One will be a row ID.
Column Two is the label
for the route as an ENT.
Column three is a column
of all the same letter.
It's a throwaway column that we need
to include because Burt expects it WTF,
right? Just roll with it and the text
examples will be in the last column,
the ones we want to classify.
We can do all this easily with
the pandas python library.
Once we formatted our data, we can run
training. Once it's finished training,
we'll use it to predict on new text data
by selecting the newly trained weights
file as input, as well as some test review
and it will output a classification,
either a good or bad review.
Now if we want to perform
automatic summarization,
we can use the same learned embeddings
well firstly to cluster them then extract
one sentence from each cluster.
This is an unsupervised technique.
These embeddings will be clustered in
high dimensional vector space where the
number of clusters is equal to the
desired number of sentences we want.
In the summary,
each cluster of sentence embeddings can
be interpreted as a set of semantically
similar sentences whose meaning can be
expressed by just one candidate sentence.
In the summary,
this candidate sentence is selected
to be the sentence who's vector
representation is closest
to the cluster center.
We then order the candidate
sentences to form a summary.
This order is determined by the position
of the sentences in their related
clusters. This technique is
considered extractive summarization.
Amazing, right? There are three
things to remember from this video.
Natural language processing is the study
of computational techniques to help
computers understand and
communicate in human languages.
Google's Burt's model.
It makes it easy for anyone to create
an NLP application greatly reducing the
amount of training, time,
data and compute necessary.
And we can perform NLP tasks like text
summarization and text classification
using birth. What do you
want to do with NLP? Next,
let me know in the comments section and
please subscribe for more programming
videos. For now, I've got to analyze
some texts, so thanks for watching.